Bis zum nächsten Mal.
so chat da bin ich wieder gesund sagen wir mal so zu 70 prozent mir läuft ein
bisschen die nase und ich muss noch ab und zu husten da müssen wir gucken ob
ob das heute funktioniert.
Wenn ich zu sehr
husten muss durch das Gelabere
oder ich zu sehr am Schniefen bin
wegen der Nase,
dann können wir heute aufzuschucken
und schucken Anna mal weiter.
Übrigens, Leute.
Hallo.
Was geht?
Heute wird geschuckt.
Handleak, shit, ja
Ja
Die Fingerleaks von vor ein paar Jahren
Die sind ja outdated, weil ich hab nicht mehr so fette Finger
Wie früher
Wartet mal
Wo hab ich jetzt
Bevor ich jetzt irgendeine Festplatte
Schucke, die große Preisfrage
Ist doch viel eher
Wo hab ich die Festplatte überhaupt hin
Äh, ah, hier, hier, Moment
Moment
Das wär's jetzt, ey.
Hier, esse.
Nee, ich muss, ich hoffe nicht, dass ich wieder fetter werde.
Ich bin sogar jetzt ein bisschen dünner geworden.
Naja, ich bin über Weihnachten ein bisschen fetter geworden.
Ich hab wieder zwischenzeitlich 85 gewogen.
Jetzt wiege ich wieder 84.
Mein Ziel war eigentlich letztes Jahr unter 80.
Was ich ja auch ganz kurz geschafft habe.
Aber irgendwie hab ich dann gegen Ende letzten Jahres wieder
zu viel gefressen und zu wenig gerannt.
Und deswegen bin ich jetzt wieder
über 80. Aber immerhin. Ich mein,
ganz ehrlich,
ich war vor ein paar
Jahren, vor, boah, das ist nicht so viel,
noch nicht so lange her, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 4, 5
Jahre oder so,
war ich bei 108,5.
Ja, da sind
ein paar 80 immer noch
super dagegen.
Wie groß bist du?
So, Leute, hier
Das hier
Wird heute
Hier, der da
Wird heute geschuckt
Äh, ich muss mal kurz das Kabel hier wegmachen
Das hängt nämlich voll im Weg
Generell habe ich die Kamera ein bisschen schräg
Oder? Hups, jetzt habe ich irgendwas runtergeschmissen
Äh, habe ich die Kamera ein bisschen
Schräg hier
Wartet mal
Moment
Mal fixen
I fix it
so okay bürgern darf ich mich nicht dann läuft mir übertrieben die nase so passt so
hallo du bist 175 bist du fast genauso groß wie ich
das heißt du warst auch deutlich zu peter pfett
soll hier der kollege wird heute geschockt man erkennt die hälfte übrigens gar nicht
sehr schlau habe ich meine kam es aber irgendwie ich meine kamera dumm eingestellt kann es sein
egal hier so rum jetzt ich glaube das problem ist ich muss die kamera ein bisschen weiter
so in die richtung machen weil was interessiert mich hier dieser komische aufbau mit mit dem mars
button im ganzen gedünges hier will man eigentlich was sehen kann ich jetzt aber gerade nicht machen
egal dann zeige ich euch mal hier 26 26 t sie geld platte wird geschockt die matte ist schräg
die matte ist ein bisschen bisschen ist die matte schräg aber das tischende das hatte ich das letzte
mal besser eingestellt guck mal hier seht ihr meine hand oder ist noch
bestimmt 20 zentimeter bis zur tischkante
also ich müsste die ganze kamera ein bisschen ich glaube mein ring light ist
einfach nicht so ganz so müsste ich das eigentlich machen aber das funktioniert
jetzt nicht
Was ist Schucken?
Schucken
heißt
auf Deutsch sowas wie
entkernen.
Und was damit gemeint ist,
so zumindest im Kontext von
im Kontext von Festplatten,
ist damit gemeint,
aus so einem externen Case,
aus so einem Ding hier,
Guck mal, aus so einem externen, eigentlich externen USB-Case, die Platte, die da drin ist, rauszubauen, um sie als normale 3,5 Zoll SATA-Platte verwenden zu können.
Für wie viel hast du die 26 Terabyte geshoppt? 499 Euro.
499, das ist für eine 26T-Platte echt gut.
Das ist ja das Schlimme.
Der Preis ist mittlerweile gut.
Ja.
Die habe ich gekauft.
Wann kam die an?
Vor einer Woche oder so?
Eineinhalb Wochen?
Hast du noch Verwendung fürs Gehäuse?
Ja, da mache ich, da mache ich,
probiere ich mal aus, ob das geht.
Da mache ich eine 8TB
WD Red rein.
Als externe Platte.
Boah, mein Nas läuft, das ist ja scheiße.
So kann ich gar nicht streamen.
Wartet mal, ich putze mir mal die Nase.
So.
Ich hoffe, das geht jetzt, Leute.
Wenn das mit der Nase nicht funktioniert,
dass mir die ganze Zeit die Nase dabei läuft
und ich irgendwas vorschniefe, das ist ja auch eklig für euch,
dann hucken wir heute nicht.
Aber ich hoffe, wir können ordentlich schucken.
Ja, also 499 ist top.
Der Witz ist, guckt euch das mal an, wenn ihr hier auf Geizhals geht.
Geizhals.
Und mal hier beispielsweise Hardware.
Festplatten.
Und mal bei internen SATA guckt und dann sagt, irgendwie macht mich die neue Geizhals.
die erweiterte filter muss man jetzt klar machen dass ich ab 26 das ist die
refurbished preis pro terabyte
rezertifiziert rezertifiziert rezertifiziert jetzt hier überhaupt
Gibt's hier überhaupt ein 26T?
Hier, 26.
Guck mal.
Die erste 26T,
die neu ist,
738 Euro.
Keck, wait.
Und die nächste, die WD Red 26,
800! The fuck?
Ist das euer Ernst, oder was?
Lull.
Da sollte ich vielleicht mal gucken,
ob ich demnächst noch mal so eine krieg.
zum Schucken.
Das Ding ist nur,
also,
es ist ein bisschen fraglich,
ob sich das mit dem Schucken überhaupt lohnt.
Weil, wenn du hier
so eine externe Platte hast, ne, so ein Ding
hier, die
hat natürlich Garantie drauf, allerdings
nur, solange sie eben so
bleibt hier.
Ich hab keine
Garantie auf eine geschuckte
26 TB Platte. Das heißt,
eigentlich könnte man sagen okay das bisschen mehr geld bei sagen wir bei
bei einer 8 22 28 t platte zum beispiel ja das bisschen das bisschen bessere
preis leistung ist es dann gar nicht wert also könnte man könnte man so
argumentieren ja nehmen wir mal die erstbeste hier die halb vier dass ihr
was halt ich schon teuer wenn man schrug kann man auch research
kaufen. Recertified
gibt es ja auch zwei verschiedene Sachen.
Recertified gibt es zweimal und zwar
einmal der Hersteller
resetet einfach nur smart und gut ist.
Kannst du eigentlich knicken.
Und es gibt mit einem Jahr Garantie
vom Hersteller Certified. Das ist in der
Tat ganz gut. Die sind aber deutlich teurer
als diese Recertified hier bei Geizhals.
Ja, ja, wir machen das Ding jetzt auch
gleich erst einmal an. Also ich werde das jetzt
gar nicht... Also ich...
Wir schließen das jetzt gleich erst mal ans Nass an.
Wir packen das jetzt aus.
Dann schließen wir das mal ans Nass an.
Gucken mal, ob wir irgendwie rauskriegen, was das ist.
SMR, CMR-Platte.
Und dann...
Schauen wir mal, ja.
Aber nebenbei, Leute.
Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Ich hab hier noch eine Pizza.
Die muss ich mir mal kurz zwei Stück reinschieben.
Ich war quasi gerade fertig.
mit Arbeiten und war mal kurz an der frischen Luft,
hab ich mir gedacht, ey,
ich habe schon Tage nicht gestreamt.
Ich hab ja versprochen,
wir schucken die Festplatte.
Alles schön, Satschensilber.
Warum?
Ich bin die ganze Woche arbeiten gewesen,
außer dienstags.
Trotz Erkältung.
Aber ich musste ja nicht
ins Office.
Was heißt spucken?
Nicht spucken, schucken.
Schucken.
Schucken heißt entkernen auf Deutsch.
Und damit ist gemeint, wenn man eine externe Platte hat, wie die hier.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein externes HDD-Gehäuse mit einer Platte drin.
Wenn man die Festplatte da ausbaut, um die als internes 3,5 Zoll Laufwerk zu verwenden.
Das nennt man schucken.
Oh, Leute, wir müssen ja noch die Linux
Ach komm, Chat
Das wird mir jetzt zu kompliziert
Ne, ne, ne, das machen wir, ich muss mich da dran gewöhnen
Sonst fange ich wieder an, fahre nur noch an
Meine VM zu benutzen
Ne, ne, ich mach mal hier
Sekunde
Ist das ein AI-Bild?
dies bis das bild sieht irgendwie fake aus kann sich kann sich genau mein finger
drauf legen aber irgendwie sieht die fake aus
erstellt so und dann während ich während ich meine pizza futterer erst
einmal mache ich hier meine mini pc an dann erzähle ich euch mal was von der
so ein bisschen sidetracken und moment deskflow muss an deskflow zack zack mini pc an festplatte
ich weiß was das datum dran so hoffe ich da geht jetzt alles an und funzt wort trinken ich habe
eine Nebenwirkung
von meiner Erkältung noch.
Ich hoffe, man versteht mich überhaupt
heute halbwegs gescheit. Ich glaube, man hört noch
ein bisschen, dass ich erkältet bin am Großen und Ganzen. Geht's, hoffe ich.
Also, ich habe eine
Nebenwirkung. Ich habe noch ein bisschen
Geruchs- und Geschmacksverlust.
Also, ich merke nur die Hälfte von der Pizza,
die ich hier habe.
Ich schmecke die nicht richtig gerade.
Aber es ist schon
besser geworden über die letzten zwei Tage.
So Sonntag, Montag war komplett weg.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es Corona war, was ich hatte.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ich hatte schon mal Corona vor ein paar Jahren.
Und das hat ganz anders angefühlt.
Es gibt einen Friseur bei uns.
Den gibt es seit 13 Jahren.
Es gibt im Hintergrund nur eine einzige Bewertung mit dem Text Super.
Ja, wahrscheinlich gehen da irgendwelche Omas hin, die nicht wissen, wie man Google Bewertungen schreibt.
hier sind wir unserer messer von eisen linux mit auf unserem messer von eisen linux mini pc
sagt jetzt war gerade mal updates ich hoffe ich muss nicht wieder als komplettes system
upgrade und noch mal rebooten ja doch doch ich muss noch mal rebooten ja jetzt kann ich
euch mal was wird sich erzählen werde ich hier meine pizza futter und zwar
auf der arbeit oder ich frage euch mal was anderes hat jemand schon von euch
schon mal kontakt gehabt mit dieser software
Moment, bevor wir das uns angucken, wollte ich gerade noch was zu sagen.
Was echt hilft ist bei Erkältung, ist wenn du so ein Inhalationsgerät hast,
mit so Salzlösung drin.
Das habe ich mir schon vor einer Weile gekauft, das ist quasi so ein Copium-Inhalationsgerät.
Ähm, hab ich vor einer Weile gekauft, weil ich ab und zu manchmal, gerade nachdem, wenn ich mehrere Stunden gestreamt hab, so einen trockenen Hals hab.
Und da hab ich so ein Ding gekauft und das ist bei Erkältung enorm nice, also richtig nice.
Das löst alles.
Gut, da läuft ja noch mehr die Nase und du musst noch mehr husten, aber es geht schneller weg.
Die Nase rebooten, ja, das wär nicht schlecht.
Was hat die so für eine Reboot-Time?
So, ich würde sagen, so
sieben, acht, neun Tage, hä?
Mehr Salz-Nasen-Spray. Ganz ehrlich,
mehr Salz-Nasen-Spray oder mit Salzlösung
inhalieren dürfte wahrscheinlich nicht so viel Unterschied sein, oder?
Ja, ach so, so,
worauf ich raus wollte. Hat jemand von euch schon mit
dieser Software zu tun gehabt?
Also ja, das ist Keypass in schlecht,
könnte man so sagen. Okay,
Sgt. Silver kennt das Ding.
Das ist schlimm, ja?
das ding das ist das ist schlimm jetzt folgendes
bei uns auf der arbeit war diese software für lange vor meiner zeit kennt ihr proxmox
Wir haben sogar
Wir benutzen heute sogar Proxmox im Stream wahrscheinlich
Für die Festplatte
Aber ja
Kennen wir
Haben wir in den letzten Streams öfter sogar schon aufgesetzt
Hier
So und diese Software
War dort wo ich arbeite
Seit keine Ahnung 20 Jahren oder so
Im Einsatz
Und jetzt
sind sie auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
was auch sehr gut ist, muss ich sagen,
das Ganze durch Keepers
abzulösen.
Okay? Also, eigentlich schon mal
ganz sinnvoll. Und jetzt
haben sie alle
Riesenaktion, weil
also,
geplant war es
folgendermaßen.
Geplant
war das folgendermaßen.
Die wollten eigentlich
dass man recht einfach umziehen kann von dieser Software zu KeyPass.
Das Problem ist nur, diese Software kann in keinem Format exportieren, was KeyPass versteht
und KeyPass kann in keinem Format importieren, was von der Software.
So.
Jetzt war der ursprüngliche Plan eigentlich.
Man exportiert das einfach in einen Plaintext XML, äh CSV, nicht XML.
CSV.
Plaintext CSV.
Und das importiert man dann, also das können die
beide. Und das importiert
man dann in
KeyPass. So.
Es war schon alles gesetzt.
Bis Ende April wird die Software uninstalled.
Keiner darf sie mehr verwenden.
Und jetzt hat unsere
Abteilung, die dafür zuständig
ist quasi für, dass alle Richtlinien eingehalten
werden und sowas. Die hat gesagt,
Moment, Moment, Leute.
Also, dass das Ende April
aninstalliert wird, finden wir gut.
Outdated alte Software wollen wir eh nicht
verwenden. Aber
ihr dürft die Passwörter nicht
exportieren in den CSV.
Weil da liegen die
ja ganz kurz unverschlüsselt
auf
eurer VM rum.
Das geht auf gar keinen Fall.
Das heißt, die einzig gangbare
Möglichkeit, die die Leute jetzt
haben ist,
dieses Ding
auf der linken Seite des Bildschirms aufzumachen,
Keypass auf der rechten
Seite des Bildschirms aufzumachen
und die Passwörter zu copy-pasten
zwischen den zwei Programmen hin und her.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
So.
Und jetzt.
dreimal dürft ihr raten, was ich gemacht hab.
Ich musste auch letztens
Passwort, äh,
wenn das nicht viele sind, Alter, wir haben Leute mit
Passwort-Saves, die sind seit 15
Jahren in Entstehen, da sind, keine Ahnung,
178 Passwörter drin oder so. Oder
570 oder sowas.
Das ist total abgedreht. Das ist, das, die
platzen teilweise.
So. Und jetzt,
Wisst ihr, was ich gemacht habe?
Oder beziehungsweise, was ich auch etwas verfeinern will
Ich musste gestern auch ein Passwort-Safe umziehen
Von einem meiner Services
Und da waren nur 12 Passwörter drin
Das hätte ich innerhalb von 5 Minuten copy-pasted
Überhaupt kein Problem
Aber ich habe mir gedacht, wenn schon
Dann mach es mal richtig
Und ich habe ein Go-Programm entwickelt
Was das kann
Ich habe eine 11 Jahre alte Library auf GitHub gefunden
11 Jahre alte Library
die Passwortsave-Files lesen kann.
Hier.
GitHub, pw-save,
golang und nicht die erste, die man findet.
Die erste, die man findet, ist die.
Die funktioniert nicht.
Ich habe hier nach pw-save
gesucht
und dann, ähm,
hoffentlich finde ich das noch.
pw-save
und da,
ah ne, ich kann jetzt gar nicht nach language,
sollte ich nicht eigentlich nach language filtern können?
Ach, nee, Code.
Nee, Repos.
Was?
Okay.
PW-Save. So, und dann hab ich...
Kann man hier nach Go filtern?
Genau, und dann hab ich ne Library
gefunden.
Uralt.
Und die hier, glaube ich,
von vor elf Jahren
und
die kann tatsächlich die
Passwortsafe-Files lesen.
Elf Jahre alte Library.
Gibt es nicht mal als Go-Modul.
Muss man mit
Go-Get runterladen.
So, und da habe ich mir ein kleines Tool
gebaut, 150 Zeilen,
was diese Sachen konvertieren kann.
Ich habe sogar den Source-Code mal kurz
angeguckt, also ganz ehrlich, das sieht
alles hier sehr
ungefährlich aus.
So, und das Gute ist,
mein Tool
konvertiert ohne das
unverschlüsselt
abzuspeichern.
Der liest die,
erstellt
eine verschlüsselte Keypass-Datei
und schreibt die da rein und dann safet er das.
Ist alles im Rahmen. Ja, im Rahmen unverschlüsselt
ist okay.
Und
das habe ich heute einem geschickt, der für die Umstellung
damit
zuständig ist, für die Umstellung von
diesem Passwort-Safe auf KeyPass und der war
richtig happy. Da habe ich gesagt, jawohl!
Endlich!
Die haben das bisher wohl irgendwie
so gemacht.
Es gibt wohl irgendwie ein Plugin
für KeyPass, das ist aber auch
outdated. Damit kann man
irgendwie mit Trick 17 die Dateien dann doch
importieren. So ein Tool ist denen viel lieber.
so jetzt gibt es aber nur ein problem wo wir gerade wieder beim thema sind dass
es teilweise echt schwierig ist ein bisschen enterprise umfeld was zu
arbeiten also der finde das super der würde das gerne benutzen
ich habe das mit go einfach aus windows extra raus gehauen das geht ja in total
easy schreibst go os windows und schon hast du denn go also in den windows
binary unter linux erzeugt für in gold ist ja super easy ich habe jetzt eine
linux version und windows version und jetzt das nächste problem der wollte das ausführen
beziehungsweise hat gefragt kannst kannst du schicken gab es alles schon github hochgeladen
und so kannst du dir angucken jetzt kann er die windows-echse nicht ausführen weil die nicht
signiert ist und jetzt muss er irgendwie erstmal zu 30.000 leuten rennen dass er unsignierte software
ausführen darf und da habe ich ihm gesagt ey weißt du was ist doch egal wir machen es einfach so wenn
es leute gibt mit einem riesen passwort safe die das nicht mehr auf die reihe kriegen bis ende
april mit copy paste und keinen bock drauf haben die können ja die können ja einfach mit mir
zusammen das auf einer linux kiste eintippen da gibt es nichts mit software signierung auf
meine linux kiste kann ich ausführt was ich will aber nicht schlecht oder
gleich mal automated das ganze was ist wenn das irgendwo benutzt wird außerhalb
von meinem team dann werde ich das auf jeden fall an die große glocke hängen
weil ihr wisst ja noch viel wichtiger als coole sachen machen ist es möglichst
breit zu treten dass man coole sachen gemacht hat
genau
ich habe ein problem ich habe jetzt euch zwar die story erzählt aber eigentlich wollte ich
ja meine pizza essen was wir dann schocken können bevor ich jetzt ewig rum mache ich
schiebe mir jetzt einfach die pizza rein in zwei minuten und dann wird geschockt
Ja, ist so
Das ist wirklich so
So blöd es klingt
Drüber reden ist fast wichtiger
Als geile Sachen zu machen
Du kannst auch weniger geile Sachen machen
Und die einfach als besonders geil verkaufen
Ich schmeck eh nix
Ich bin erkältet gewesen
Jetzt die letzten paar Tage
Und ich hab die letzten Tage auch
Geschmacks-Geruchsverlust.
Die letzten zwei Tage
kommt es langsam zurück.
Klingt nach
Late Corona.
Aha.
Was soll Late Corona sein?
Ich meine, erkältet bin ich ja jetzt, also es kann ja nicht late sein
Oder meinst du, eines der neuesten Coronas?
Kann auch sein, aber glaube ich nicht
Ich hatte Corona schon mal vor 2, 3 Jahren
Das hat sich ganz anders angefühlt als das jetzt
ich schmecke ja nicht viel aber leute die pizza ist wirklich nice das ist
eine selbstgemachte pizza also nicht ich meine mutter hat die gemacht ja das ist
eine selbstgemachte pan pizza also in so einer bakkofanne hände das lieber pizzahut
So American Style Pizza
Und
Es ist selbst gemachter Teig
Mit
Thunfisch
Tomatensauce
Und Käse drüber
Das schmeckt besser als Pizza Hut
ab jetzt auch die dinge brutalst fertig immer
So hälfte ist weg wird geschockt
Ja, wir machen gerade ASMR-Eating-Sounds.
Du bist genau rechtzeitig da.
Wir müssen uns stärken,
dass wir die Festplatte ordentlich geschuckt kriegen.
Okay.
Ich hätte eigentlich schnell fressen sollen,
bevor ich den Stream anmache, aber
Tja, kann man jetzt nichts ändern.
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt habe ich Thunfisch auf die Erde geschmissen.
Warte mal.
Äh, Chat, was war bei Festplatten nochmal das Schlechte?
SMR oder CMR?
SMR war das Schlechte, oder?
es ist das was man nicht haben will
kann sich tippen gescheit
ja es hat mir erst kacke genau das mann zu einem kopf durcheinander
eine reaction ich kann euch voll schmatzen dabei
drei viertel weg gleich haben
gibt pizza die man oder gemacht hat eine american style pan pizza
mit thunfisch
ich hab nicht vergessen meine pillen gleich zu nehmen
macht es mal weg hier
und wie war die woche bei euch so bis jetzt
auch gleich alles weg ja anstrengend ja
sagt manchmal
wobei auch anstrengende wochen ganz ganz nice sein können es kommt immer darauf an was das
ist was ein anstrengend ja wenn schon montags bis freitags oder um ihr von
sie sagt bis freitags dauern gemiete ist sonst auch anstrengend aber nicht nice
neuer job onboarding videos in welcher branche sucht silva das verraten
es geht ja danke schön für den sub und danke an denjenigen freund hat schon mal
eine gestoppt habe ich glaube ich nicht richtig gesehen danke auch an dich ich
sehe es gar nicht und ich kann ja auch nicht scrollen weil ich fettige finger von der pizza
ab transport und logistik und jeder musste keine geldwäsche compliance
stinksbums videos machen
bei euch herrscht herrscht meeting verbot es wird zu wenig gearbeitet moment
es hat mal einer gecheckt dass das vielleicht keine gute idee ist dass alle
80 prozent nur noch mieten ich glaube ich nicht dass es lange hält
da kann ich leute jetzt wird geschockt
händen abputzen so schockte hallo
kann man was trinken um eine pille nehmen oder jetzt los
also erstmal packen wir nur aus dann schließen wir die ans nass an gucken
mal rauskriegen ob es erst einmal mehr ist ach scheiß drauf leute scheiß drauf
ganz ehrlich ich habe nur bis 1930 zeit und bis vielleicht 20 uhr zeit
wir schrucken jetzt gleich scheiß drauf jolo jolo schocking und wenn sie und wenn
es eine cdr platte ist und wenn es ja mehr platt platte das habe ich halt
gelitten wir schrucken jetzt die festplatte
Kannst du mal für Low IQs
den Unterschied von SAN zu NAS erklären?
Also,
in der Regel ist der Unterschied eigentlich,
dass NAS Storage ist,
der ganz normal über das Netzwerk angesprochen wird
und SAN
ist quasi eigene Infrastruktur
nur für Storage.
Ich glaube, das ist der größte Unterschied.
Also, bei SAN hast du so etwas wie
ein eigenes Fiber Channel Netzwerk.
Kann man das Netzwerk nennen?
eigene, du hast eigene
äh, Switche, weiß ich nicht, sind das
Switche überhaupt? Du hast eigene Switche,
hast eigene Glasfaserkabel, nur für dieses
ähm
Storage Backend quasi.
Ja, es gibt
genau, Fiber Channel over Ethernet gibt's auch,
aber
ich kenn das noch von früher,
da war wirklich komplett eigene Fiber Channel Infrastruktur.
Also das ist eigentlich in der Regel
der größte Unterschied.
Also NAS ist Storage,
den du direkt als Netzwerk anstöpselst
und ansprichst.
SAN ist eigene Storage-Infrastruktur,
die du in der Regel so ansprechen kannst,
wie als wären es eigene Platten.
Also du bekommst bei einem
SAN
dann Laufwerke zugewiesen
an deinen Server
und die werden angesprochen wie
normale
Block-Devices, die direkt am Server dranhängen.
Unter der Haube ist dann Fiber Channel, da werden dann irgendwelche Loons gemappt und sonst was.
Ist aber wurscht.
Du bekommst in der Regel ein dediziertes Block-Device.
So, bei NAS greifst du über das Netzwerk auf den Storage zu.
Es gibt natürlich auch so Hybrid-Dinger, wo man sich dann drüber ein bisschen streiten kann.
Was ist es?
So ISCSI ist so ein Ding.
Man kann sagen, es geht ja über das Netzwerk, aber es sind auch eigene Laufwerke.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, so der größte Unterschied ist eigentlich, SAN ist eigene Infrastruktur, nur für Storage. NAS ist über bestehende Netzwerk-Infrastruktur-Storage.
Warum macht man das? Sind die billiger als normale interne Platten? Ja, die sind deutlich billiger.
Moment
Ich glaube ich meinte du meinst Schucken oder
Jaja
Die sind billiger
Die sind billiger als
Die sind deutlich billiger
499 Euro zu 750 Euro
Jetzt haben wir einfach
Jetzt wird YOLO Schuckt
Okay Leute
Auf geht's
Wollen wir sagen holen wir mal das I fix it kit
muss man kurz hier meine sehe ich nämlich auch was eine vorschau einblenden also ich
war mal kurz diesen ganzen krempel hier weg brauchen wir nicht hier das war mal
weg, dass ich ein bisschen Platz hier hinten hab.
So.
Dann schauen wir mal.
Okay.
Kannst du kurz erklären, worauf man
achten sollte, wenn man sowas
kaufen will? Ja, aus meiner
langjährigen Shocking-Erfahrung,
also dem ersten Laufwerk, den ich
heute in meinem Leben schucke,
kann ich dir sagen,
am besten ist, wie bei
vielem, du guckst vorher auf Reddit,
ob irgendjemand schon mal eine dieser platten geschockt hat und ob der
gecheckt hat was drin ist das habe ich nämlich auch gemacht ich habe das
nämlich nicht einfach auf gut glück gekauft ich habe auf reddit geguckt was
es gerade für gute externe platten zum schuppen gibt und da kam unter anderem
diese sie geld desktop expansion bei raus ist das nicht verklebt ich habe
Keine Ahnung, es gibt ein Video dazu.
Es gibt ein Video dazu.
Mal gucken, wenn wir es nicht aufkriegen, muss ich mal gucken,
ob ich mir ein Video dazu angucke, wie man das aufkriegt.
Erstmal muss ich hier mal ein I-Fix-It auspacken.
Was braucht man da hier?
Das braucht man höchstwahrscheinlich.
Ey, Leute, damit habe ich mir mal brutals in den Finger geschnitten.
Davor habe ich Schiss.
Das ist kein Messer, ja, das ist nicht scharf.
Also das ist nicht irgendwie großartig.
Also du tust dir nicht weh.
Aber wenn du da mit ordentlichem Schmackes schneidest, dann schneidest du.
Ich weiß nicht mal, welcher Finger es war.
Ich glaube hier.
Da habe ich mal irgendwas durch und bin abgerutscht.
Und da habe ich fast bis zum Knochen mit dem Ding hier durch den Finger geschnitten.
Also aufpassen.
Aber hört mal mein Geschniefe zu sehr
Ja, also wenn es euch zu sehr auf den Sack geht
Müssen wir an einem anderen Tag schucken
Ich kann es nicht ändern, Mann
Na, es läuft
Je stumpfer, je gefährlicher
Ey, mit einem richtig scharfen Versäumchen
Mit den Fingern durchgeschnitten
So, was brauchen wir denn hier sonst noch?
Ich weiß es nicht
Gucken wir uns das erstmal an
Also ich denke mal, diese
Also was wir höchstwahrscheinlich brauchen werden
Ist wahrscheinlich diese Dinger hier
Sieht aus, als kannst du da mit Gitarre spielen, aber das sind so zum reinstecken und hebeln und sowas.
Das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Den da brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Ich hole jetzt mal das Gehäuse und dann packen wir das aus und gucken uns das mal an.
Kann man das bei der Gelegenheit ja auch gleich vielleicht damit aufmachen.
Shocking Time.
So, hier.
Oh, Leute.
Das Warranty Seal wird gebroken.
Wird gebraked.
Warranty Seal broken.
Direkt.
Abmahnung.
Auf, geh raus.
Die will sich nicht schucken lassen.
Ich merke das schon.
Okay, Riesenplatte
Hier ist wahrscheinlich das Netzteil drin, vermute ich mal
Was haben wir denn hier am Start?
Wie? What the f...
Alter, was ist das alles?
Ah, Kekona-Stecker und sowas
Also wir haben einmal diesen hässlichen
Ekligen
USB
B oder wie dieser Kram heißt, dieser Stecker?
Micro USB B.
Der hässlichste Stecker aller Zeiten.
Ja.
Riecht ja Rotz, das Ding.
Ja, Rotz heute im wahrsten Sinne.
Und hier haben wir erstmal 100.000 verschiedene...
...Steckteile.
Steckteile.
Stecker für Steckteile.
Netzteilstecker.
Aber hier
normale Powerbrick.
Wahrscheinlich 5 Volt. Ne, was?
12 Volt
1,5
Ampere.
12 Volt. Okay, keine 5.
Wundert mich jetzt.
Aber okay.
Und dann haben wir hier
alle möglichen Stecker.
Wir haben irgendwie
zweimal?
Ne, das ist hier. Das ist
unserer hier.
Was ist der hier?
Wie funsten das?
Chat, ich bin
hart verwirrt.
Warum sind
da so viele Stecker drin?
Und
welcher davon ist jetzt unserer?
Das sind zweimal die gleichen, oder?
Ersatz, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Okay, Push.
Und jetzt muss man das hier wahrscheinlich so irgendwie da...
So, okay, naja.
Gut, bin ich froh, wenn alles nur noch USB-C ist.
Aber wie gesagt, ich will die externe Sache eh nicht verwenden.
so weg weg aufmachen hier zack handbuch weg verpackung weg und zack riesen
verpackung an sich ist die gar nicht so groß hier dieses externe gehäuse das
externe case welchen grenzen macht eigentlich einen ganz guten eindruck
Für ein externes Case relativ dünn.
Aber guckt, da sieht man die Platte auch schon drin.
Das seht ihr hier.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn alle Stricke reißen und ich dieses Ding gar nicht aufkriege,
dann nehme ich einfach meinen Knippeck-Seitenschneider und mache hier neben das Ding ab.
Guck mal, es geht schon kaputt hier.
Massive Quality.
Huge.
So, wie kriegt man das jetzt auf?
Wie könnte man das aufkriegen?
Irgendjemand eine chlorreiche Idee?
Irgendwie drunter oder so?
Hm
Das ist in der Tat gar nicht so
Gar nicht so iets wie gedacht
Hm
Hammer und drauf.
Ja, Moment mal.
Kaputt machen und rausholen kann ich das.
Das ist nicht so schwierig.
Aber.
Ne, hier ist nichts drunter.
Okay, lasst uns das nochmal genau angucken.
Kann man hier irgendwie neben rein?
Fühlt sich jetzt eigentlich.
Nicht so an.
Sieht das so aus, als kommt man hier neben rein?
Ah, doch, doch, doch.
Oder? Wartet mal.
Auf jeden Fall
will ich mir heute nicht mehr in den Finger schneiden.
Nochmal.
Also ich habe gesehen,
Es gibt ein Video auf YouTube.
Das gucken wir uns mal schnell an.
Wie das ging.
Boah, mir läuft die Nase.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das heute auf die Reihe kriege.
Das Schlimme ist,
ich muss die ganze Zeit nach unten gucken.
Dann läuft die Nase noch mehr.
Ja, 26, hier. Seagate Desktop Expansion. Was habt ihr gesagt? Teardown? Teardown heißt das glaube ich, ne? Ah ja, hier genau. Sehr gut.
Step by Step.
This is going to be a quick video.
Äh, was?
Ah
I've had
Okay
Jetzt probieren wir mal aus
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert
Also
Das ist wahrscheinlich die bessere Kreditkarte
Sogar noch dünner
Als eine Kreditkarte
Wir brauchen jetzt irgendein komisches
Metallding
Zum anheben
Also quasi
Würde ich mal sagen
Sowas hier
So ein Zahnarzt
So ein Zahnarztding
So, hier
Hier durch
Und dann an
Ah, guck dir mal, seht ihr das?
Das Funks
So halbwegs.
So richtig gut
fand ich es aber nicht.
Ah doch.
Also ihr seht,
da gibt es ein Loch hier.
Aber gut, ganz ehrlich, gut ist echt was anderes.
wirklich gut funktionieren tut das net
meint ihr das ist ein kleber hier drinnen deswegen geht es muss ich das aufschneiden
er kommt auf jeden fall jetzt schon mal hier rein an der stelle kommt mal
Boah ist das kacke alter ist das schrott ist es freudig das mäße freudig
Wenn ich das vielleicht so hier drunter
Ha ha ich hab's leute seht ihr das ja
Exzellent! Exzellenter Schucker!
So, jetzt brauche ich diese anderen Dinger hier. Das kann man aufmachen.
Aber den hier nehme ich hier da rein.
Dann kann ich das Messer nämlich raus machen.
Ja, perfekt.
So, jetzt kann ich das Messer raus machen.
Und jetzt versuche ich, ohne mir in die Finger zu schneiden,
Das andere war, hätte ich auch noch aufzukriegen.
Also man kriegt es auf jeden Fall...
Wow, Leute, ganz close.
Fast mit den Fingern geschnitten.
Ich muss das weg, weg von mir machen.
Oder...
Ah, haha.
Oh, ich hab die...
Ich hab gar nicht das Mikrofon am Mund.
Jetzt, jetzt hat es verloren, Leute.
Jetzt hat es verloren.
Der Shockingmeister schlägt zu, Leute.
Massive Sugars.
Massive Shocking...
Bam.
Easy.
Sag ich da nur.
Extrem...
Easy as a...
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Und jetzt, ganz wichtig, ganz wichtig.
Get rekt.
Gut.
So, weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier drinnen?
Eine 26 Terabyte Seagate
Barracuda.
Die es offiziell gar nicht gibt.
Es gibt keine 26 Terabyte Barracudas.
Es muss also irgendwas Spezielles für diese SSD.
Wahrscheinlich, und das habe ich auch auf Reddit gelesen,
wahrscheinlich sind das Exos,
die als Barracuda gelabelt für diese Exos,
also bei der Qualitätskontrolle durchgefallene Exos,
sind das wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich,
soweit ich das auf Reddit gelesen habe,
soweit die Vermutung da geht.
So, jetzt kommt das Nächste.
Wie kriege ich das jetzt hier raus?
Oh, guck mal, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus hier, hä?
Zack!
Oh, was ist das?
Wait a minute.
Das, seht ihr das?
Das hängt an irgendeinem komischen Band.
Warranty void?
Ich brauche...
Chat, ich glaube,
die Warranty
wäre jetzt auch schon
Void.
It's a Hammer Drive
with CMR. Hammer
ist übrigens eine sehr coole Technologie.
Chat, soll ich
euch mal kurz erklären, was
HAMR bei Festplatten ist?
Das ist richtig
nice.
Also, soweit ich das im Kopf, Helium gefüllt.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Kombination Helium gefüllt,
aber es werden Materialien verwendet,
die es erlauben, dass man quasi kleinere Sektoren hat.
und diese materialien sind allerdings schwieriger zu magnetisieren und deswegen hat man einen laser
im schreib lese kopf der erhitzt die stelle kurz weil erhitztes material sich einfacher
magnetisieren lässt deswegen ist es hit es ist also ist quasi
ein laser im schreib lese kopf der das zum richtigen zeitpunkt kurz erhitzt
das material so das ist h wenn ich das jetzt richtig im kopf habe ist h am r
hit es ist für was er steht keine ahnung
woher weiß ich mit welcher festplatte typisch mal nass befüllen muss wenn du
keine Ahnung hast und nicht
so Aktionen machen willst wie ich,
also ich will damit nicht sagen,
dass ich großartig Harnung hätte, weil eigentlich ist es
auch gar keine so gute Idee sein, Nass mit solchen Dingen
zu betreiben, weil es wirklich
zuverlässig sein soll. Dann
mach so einen Scheiß nicht,
dann kauf dir
ein Seagate Einwolf für Nassbetrieb
und gut ist.
Kost habe halte bis ich mehr.
Kurz mal Nase putzen.
So, wieder am Starten.
So, können wir mal hier reingucken, Chat.
Also, wir sehen hier, dass wir so komisches Gebensel, Gebammel dran haben.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich reiße das jetzt einfach mal ab, weil das brauchen wir eh nicht.
Oder?
Ich schraub das mal raus.
Ich schraube das einfach mal ab.
Schadet ja auch nichts.
Ach, guck mal, ich hab's schon ab.
Null.
Dann machen wir Jotun auch nochmal raus.
Ich mein, schadet ja...
Schadet ja nichts.
Tschüss.
Ah, jetzt ist es ab.
Okay.
Ausgeschuckt hat sich's.
Na, ob ich an das Ding meine andere Platte hängen will?
Was ist denn das hier?
Das sieht aus wie ein Raspberry Pi-Kamera-Kabel.
Ah, hier, guck mal.
Hier ist der USB-Anschluss.
hallo kamera please einmal scharf stellen kamera wenn es nicht zu viel
verlangt ist er guckt hier ist der usb anschluss rollo runter
ok ja dann machen wir diesen kram einfach hier mal hier mal ab
pappt eklig wer weiß was für giftige kleber dinger ich jetzt an den fingern
habe
so und jetzt haben wir hier was ist das das ist okay das ist schon mal nice
ding den kreml komme ab machen ab machen naja leckt mich es ist schon mal und
Das ist das Allerwichtigste.
Ein stinknormales SATA-Laufwerk.
Seht ihr das?
Ganz normales SATA.
Das ist sehr gut.
Das ist, um nicht zu sagen,
exzellent.
Weil ansonsten hätten wir ziemliche Probleme,
wenn es kein normales SATA-Laufwerk wäre.
Das war SATA auf Rädern.
So, mal gucken,
wie wir diesen Kram hier abkriegen.
Vielleicht, wenn ich Glück habe, passt hier
der gleiche.
Oder auch nicht.
Hm.
Der passt nicht richtig.
Wartet mal. Dann probieren wir mal den
etwas fetteren aus.
Der passt.
Guck hier, jetzt können wir abmachen.
Und schon haben wir ganz normale
mounting dinger nur 3,5 zoll sata ist doch top
ok also leute ich muss sagen das ging jetzt schon einfacher als gedacht habe
oder das war jetzt an sich wir mussten uns ein bisschen den guide angucken aber
an sich war das sehr easy das war easy shocking
It's it's schock den mache ich auch kleine ab
Okay, das ist vielleicht nicht so schlau max
Habe ich bis zu viel abgezogen von dem pap aber das ist ja nicht schlimm
so sieht aus wie eine ganz normale platte jetzt machen wir noch die dinge hinten raus
sogar ohne blut ja ja ich einmal hätte ich mir fast den finger geschnitten weil
ich natürlich auch wieder so toll in meine richtung schneiden musste
So, fertig geschuckt.
Leute, da ist sie.
Wir suchen jetzt mal nach dieser Seriennummer.
Online.
Und gucken, ob wir da irgendwas rausfinden drüber.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, PSID.
Das brauchen wir jetzt, glaube ich, nicht so unbedingt.
Äh.
Waren mal kurz den Screenshot davon.
Zack.
Da sind wir wieder.
Screenshot gemacht.
Also, ST.
Sollen sie mal kurz danach suchen.
Kann Paint mittlerweile Text erkennen oder sowas?
Ne, ne.
ST26000?
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt für Copilot.
D?
DM, oder?
DM000, oder?
Lest ihr das auch so, Chat?
DM000.
Ah, guck mal.
249 Dollar.
Okay, das sind die Dinger.
Reddit.
Okay.
Aha.
Sogar Smart-Unterstützung, oder wie?
Cool, oder?
Gibt sogar Smart Support jetzt für die Platten mittlerweile.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe auch schon die Vermutung gehabt, dass das Exos sind.
Ja, sehr schön.
Pock.
PSID ist die, die man braucht, wenn man Garantiefall aufmachen will, oder?
Ist das so?
PSID Seagate.
PSID.
Ja, ja, Garantie.
Hat das Garantie?
Ja, ja, da hat das nicht.
Okay.
Oh, gut.
Dann.
würde ich sagen,
müsste man hier das Ding wieder
saugen.
Ganz viel Dreck drauf.
Das ist der große Bruder.
Also.
Ah.
Das ist bestimmt eine Exos,
die Qualitätstest nicht bestanden hat. Könnte schon sein. Okay, dann würde ich sagen,
stecken wir uns das mal rein. So, erstmal hier den Kram wegmachen. Ich packe mal kurz
mein I fix it Krempel wieder ein, weil ansonsten ich kenne mich, sonst lasse ich das ewig liegen
und finde danach nichts mehr.
Okay, gut.
Zack.
Zack, zack.
Der kommt hier in die Ecke, der kommt wieder rüber.
Gut ist.
So.
Dann müssen wir das Ding jetzt mal...
Oh, habe ich da überhaupt noch...
Ha, wie geht denn das jetzt?
Brauche ich dafür Platten?
Oder irgendwelche Sachen?
Moment.
Also das hier ist so ein Tray vom Nass.
Wollen wir mal gucken, wie wir das da dran kriegen.
Die Festplatte mit dem Laser drin.
Jaja, das ist ja auch eine
Heat-Assisted-Festplatte.
So, da muss das jetzt irgendwie drauf.
Äh.
Chatge...
Ähm.
Wo ist denn das jetzt?
Pull.
Pull?
Da steht, guck mal, da steht Pull
Hier, Pull
Ja, wenn die Kamera sich mal ordentlich
Pull
Ich pulle mal
Aha
Okay, jetzt habe ich das abgepullt und weiter
Äh
Moment, und was genau
hat das jetzt gebracht?
Ich pulle das auf der anderen Seite
auch mal ab
Alter, es ist fest, fuck
Das lässt sich nicht abholen
Doch jetzt
Und das reicht jetzt oder wie?
So ganz verstehe ich die Logik noch nicht
Und jetzt?
Ah guck mal
Jetzt geht das einfach rein
Und wenn ich das jetzt hier neben wieder dran mache
Dann ist die fest oder wie?
Aber dass man was sieht
Nicht, dass ich das irgendwie checken würde, was ich hier gerade mache.
So, okay.
Das ist mal eine merkwürdige Festplattenwechselrahmenstelz.
Aber es scheint zu funktionieren.
das Ding ist
das ist ein Minis Forum
Minis Forum ist das
warte mal
Minis Forum
okay ja gut
dann hol ich mal das Nass
Da könnt ihr jetzt gleich nicht mehr zugucken.
Ihr dürft euch jetzt nur noch angucken, wie ich das da reinstöpsel, weil ansonsten habe ich nicht genug Platz.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Ne, das sieht man nicht, ne?
Das ist zu groß.
Ja.
Fuck.
So.
Dann gehen wir mal zurück.
Takt.
Genau.
In fünf Luft.
Und jetzt schließen wir mal hier Strom an.
Am Nass.
Wie das die coolen Leute sagen.
Oder manche auf YouTube sprechen jetzt auch Nass aus.
Das Nass.
das Nas läuft.
Okay.
Und jetzt muss ich das Nas noch irgendwie
strommäßig anstöpseln.
Dafür machen wir jetzt einfach
mal die Kamera aus, würde ich sagen.
Die brauchen wir eh nicht mehr.
Das Ring Light machen wir auch aus
und jetzt stöpseln wir das dran.
Wir machen jetzt nochmal hier den Strommess-Teil dran,
damit ich euch gleich sagen kann, was das verbraucht.
Und jetzt machen wir das nass an.
Okay.
Jetzt war ein bisschen gebootet erst.
Hast du irgendwie Nightmode auf dem Lino?
Ah ja, hast recht.
Jetzt ist der Nightmode aus.
Ja.
Hast recht, war Nightmode.
Oh, während das nass bootet...
Während das bootet...
Machen wir kurz hier nochmal Update.
Coolbox.
Oh ja.
coolbox
oh ja
dann update ich auch mal
ok
also ssh
chat warum geht das nicht
Moment.
Äh, warum bootet mein
Nass nicht?
Hab ich das
vielleicht im falschen
Decker drin?
Äh.
Chat?
Das gefällt mir aber nicht.
Ah, jetzt.
Es hat einfach nur gebraucht.
Okay.
Ich hab nix gesagt.
So.
Ich lösch mal meine Bash-History.
Wer weiß, will nix leaken.
Okay.
Geh mal nach Keckel.
So.
DF-H.
Jetzt werden wir erst einmal
das ganze ZFS-Gedöns anlocken.
Äh.
Das...
Stoppen wir wieder.
Also, hier haben wir das.
So, HDD ist die 2TB-Platte.
Die brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Also, schauen wir mal, was wir da so haben.
Def, SD, A und SDB.
So, SDA ist die...
Ah, hier.
Das ist er doch.
SCA.
Also.
23,6.
Ja gut, das ist wieder Rechenfrage.
Wie recht ist?
TB-Bytes sind 23,65
und
wie die
TB rechnen, sind es dann halt 26.
So.
Stimmt.
Smart.
Smart CTL.
Oh, was? Minus A?
oder irgendwas.
Irgendwas minus A.
Smart CTL.
Smart CTL minus A.
Def.
Def SDA. Irgendwie so.
Oha.
Guck mal hier.
Da steht sogar CMR plus Hammer
hinten dran.
Ach Quatsch.
Schön.
Es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal kein billig
Schrott.
3G nur?
Oh, hast du das gesehen?
Ich sehe hier 6, 6, 0.
Ah, currently 3, okay.
Hä?
Äh.
Okay, whatever.
Keine Ahnung, was der hier für Schmerzen hat.
Leicht, weil Standby.
Weißt du, die ist noch im Standby.
ich glaube nicht dass das mass nur 33 kann
smart minus x
30.000 dinger
Ja, Smartware hat das Wissen schon auch für sich.
Zwei Platten? Quatsch.
Das Ding hat fünf Einschübe.
Wir können mal gucken, was der bei
STB sagt.
Aber das könnte tatsächlich sein,
dass es nur... Das ist wahrscheinlich nur eine
Dreier, die andere, die ich... Moment mal.
Hä?
ja die hat die hat 6
kein test wie konnte man noch einmal linux smart jetzt ist denn bei eidel
ist states ich weiß dass es funktioniert
Aber ich weiß den...
So?
Kann man abfragen, ob es
Standby ist?
Ne, die AI lügt.
Linux
get
FHD ist in Standby
Ja
Adipa minus C
FSC a
Drive State ist unknown
Active
Okay, na gut ich mein ganz ehrlich
mkfs fdst minus sca und jetzt sagen wir einfach mal mkfs ext4 oder xfs eigentlich wurscht def sca
beim usf
wir machen jetzt nichts auf erst falls es dann drauf hat funktioniert mauns def
sc a nach mnt funst mnt sagt aber haben wir noch hier
4 aber doch hier noch das einzige was wir so machen
block size 128 vielleicht nicht so geil jobs piercing runtime job name ja wenn
das war was drauf schreiben geht doch klar oder
Wartet mal.
Und jetzt?
Moment, wir brechen das nochmal kurz ab.
Smart.
SDA.
Temux.
Alter, die Festplatte macht komische Geräusche, ey.
Brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr, brr.
Okay, phew.
xfs oder x4 was wäre dann besser? Ist eigentlich egal.
So und was sagt das Ding jetzt?
Sagt immer noch current 3, naja gut.
Was auch immer, ob das stimmt, keine Ahnung.
Aber mehr als 270 wird die wahrscheinlich eh nicht hergeben.
Wollen wir mal einen Self-Test machen auf der Disk?
sata also drei wenn selbst wenn es drei gigabit die sekunde ist ist das mehr als 240 das sind
gerade mal 2 gigabit sata 3 max transfer speed sata 3,0 gb
Das macht aber eigentlich keinen Sinn
Das ist Blödsinn
Also die Platte gibt halt auch
einfach nicht mehr her, das ist schon
Also es ist vollkommen fein hier, 250
270 MB die Sekunde
Vollkommen in Ordnung
Kannst nichts sagen, hab ich
keinen Schmerzen mit
So, mal die Block Size ein bisschen kleiner, so 4K
Äh
Äh, nein
Die Anzeige stimmt nicht wirklich
Okay, ja, ist auch so ungefähr
Ungefähr gleich schnell
Näh, also ist aber okay
Ist vollkommen fein, was die Platte packt
Kann man sich jetzt nicht
beschweren eigentlich.
So, löschen wir das mal.
Dann darf er noch einen
Self-Test machen.
Def.
Oder auch nicht.
Äh.
Moment, nee, nicht Smart CTL.
HD-PAM, oder?
Was?
T-Long?
Aha.
So schnell geht das jetzt.
Extended Self-Test.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was?
Nee.
abortet dass das gebe ich mir jetzt
die ganze festplatte zu schreiben
das wird wahrscheinlich über den tag
dauern 26 arbeit bei 240 bei 240 mb
oder sagen wir mal 250 MB die Sekunde.
Das sind 10 Sekunden
2,5
Gig.
100 Sekunden 25 Gig.
1000 Sekunden 250
Gig.
10.000 Sekunden
2,5T.
Also
das braucht schon eine weile das dauert bestimmt zwei tage oder so das zu
beschreiben komplett wie viele ride zyklen kann die gibt das das gibt das
das bei festplatten in der form überhaupt
ja chat ich würde mal sagen schocking erfolgreich oder nice geschockt
So, jetzt probiere ich nochmal kurz rauszukriegen, wie viel die Platte braucht.
Ich ziehe mal die andere raus.
Ich ziehe die 2 Terabyte mal kurz raus.
Oh, die ist sogar im Betrieb relativ sparsam.
Wir sind jetzt bei 21 Watt.
Eidel.
Und das Nass an sich hat 14 Watt oder so.
14 Watt Eidel.
12, 13, 14 Watt Eidel.
Das schwankt immer ein bisschen.
HD-PA-Y ist es, glaube ich.
Dev-SDA.
Issuing Sleep Command.
Jetzt sind wir bei 15.
16,
15 Watt.
Ja, das ist okay. Damit kann ich ehrlich gesagt leben.
Wenn die da so rumeidelt.
Also wenn,
da kommen jetzt ja noch ein paar Platten dabei.
Aber dann bin ich, wenn die
Festplatten im Stand-by sind,
bin ich so bei
22 Watt Idle oder sowas.
Das ist vollkommen
fein für mein NAS.
Damit bin ich mehr als
zufrieden.
Das ist schon okay.
So, jetzt habe ich die 2TB Platte wieder reingemacht.
Mal gucken.
Ob er die jetzt checkt?
Ja, er checkt, dass die wieder da ist.
Okay.
Jetzt ist aber das STC wieder da.
Wohl.
Na gut.
Okay.
Chat, das Schucken hat gut funktioniert, oder?
Das ging sehr unproblematisch.
Problematisch. Knapp eine Stunde geschuckt, inklusive Festplatten-Tests und allem.
Jetzt halt die Preisfrage, die ich nicht beantworten kann und die ich bis die Festplatte mal kaputt geht auch nicht beantworten werden könne.
Wie stabil die auf Dauer ist.
Also ob die vielleicht in zwei Wochen oder zwei Monaten schon kaputt geht, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich würde jetzt mal sagen, eher nicht, weil das ist eine externe 26TB Festplatte, die ist ja auch dafür gedacht, jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag nur rumzustehen, ja, auch um ab und zu mal was drauf zu schreiben.
Und der Unterschied zwischen das Ding idelt rum im Standby oder eine externe Platte wird ab und zu mal angestöpselt, dürfte vom Nutzungsverhalten jetzt nicht so der große Unterschied sein zwischen dem, wie ich sie benutze und wie sie gedacht ist.
Ich lasse die auch nicht 24-7 hier hochgespinnt
Die spinnen nur hoch
Wenn ich auf mein Last zugreife
Zum Lesen oder Schreiben
Gibt Platt die 24-7 gemacht sind
Ja aber ich will da keine 24-7 Platten
Das kostet mir zu viel Strom
Und macht ja keinen Sinn
Ich schreibe da vielleicht alle paar Tage mal was drauf
Oder lese da alle paar Tage was von runter
Die ganzen aktiven Sachen
Auf dem Last
die sind auf dem raid auf dem ssd raid 1 kukier ist dann ist ein z pool status
hier ist ein rät ups hier das sind 1 mit ssds dann läuft laufen die ganzen vor
allem zum container drauf spin down parade race kann schwierig sein
Gute, guter Einwand, da hast du recht.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wie gut das geht mit ZFS, weil ZFS schreibt ja öfters da mal irgendwelche Housekeeping-Sachen und so drauf.
Das müssen wir aber nicht...
ZFS spinnen, wobei, wir haben ja noch ein paar Minuten.
Lasst uns das doch mal...
Lasst uns das doch mal ausprob...
Alter, was ist das?
Fuck, Feedback-Hub?
das ist doch mal ausprobieren ok an mount an mount mnt
es sieht so aus als muss die platte grad noch drauf schreiben oder die
spinnen da und deswegen konnte die nicht anbauten machen wir doch hier mal jetzt
einen fs create das kann ich mir immer nicht merken haben wir hier vielleicht
noch was hier
create jetzt etwas create da haben wir doch moment das ist für encryption wir
machen zwar mit encryption an genau erstellen eines cfs speicherpools zfs
z pool create genau z pool create ja
def
oder doch
ist ja
okay
und jetzt
encryption dataset mit encryption drauf
schockt safe
minus minus passphrase oder sowas war das
Shit, Alter, das weißt du ja nicht.
ZFS, Create, Pass,
Brace.
Was ist denn ZFS?
ZFS ist ein
Filesystem, was
sehr viele Features hat, unter anderem
Native Encryption,
On-the-Fly
Compression,
verschiedene Rate Level,
automatisches
checksum regelmäßige checksum checks ob die dateien nicht kaputt sind du kannst du was
wir die application machen das brauche aber so viel rahmen und würde ich nicht
einschalten und 1000 andere sachen also zfs ist sehr pock ihr kommt nicht drauf was das
passwort ist leute ihr könnt ich werde das nie raten ob top secret best practice passwort
Gibt einige Settings, die dann die Platten in Ruhe lassen
Weißt du welche?
Bin mal gespannt, was das jetzt macht
Also
Wir machen jetzt nichts hier auf die Platte, okay
Ich muss als erstes erstmal auslesen können
Ob die Platte überhaupt im Standby ist oder nicht
war mal chat gpt wie kann ich will unter linux rausfinden ob eine hdd im standby ist die packen
einst ab das haben wir doch gerade ausprobiert das hat nicht funktioniert weil drive set ist
Aha, Smart CTL, minus i, Dev SCA.
Power Mode was idle.
Okay, wenn ich jetzt HD Palm mache, Spin Down.
Standby, okay.
Okay, also so kann ich schon mal rausfinden, ob das Ding Standby ist.
So, theoretisch müssten wir jetzt gucken, ob der Kram halt wieder aufwacht von alleine oder nicht.
Im Prinzip können wir jetzt eigentlich nichts weitermachen, außer Däumchen drehen und gucken, ob die Platte aufwacht oder nicht.
Und wenn die Platte wieder aufwacht, dann gucken, woran es liegt.
wobei das gucken woran es liegt können wir jetzt auch schon da gab es doch so
einen hat man linux kummer irgendwas mit fett jetzt ich weiß aber es fängt glaube
ich wirklich mit fett an geht nicht darum dass ich wieder zu genommen habe
fett blk oder irgendwie sowas gab es da doch wie hieß das denn
nicht lsbs videos command get all events irgendwie sowas und dass das war hier das
Es hieß irgendwas mit Fett.
Fettstat oder sowas?
How can I monitor this guy?
Es hieß irgendwas mit Fett.
Fett Trace.
Das kann sein, ja.
Was ist das? Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ja, das meine ich, genau.
Hier, FAT.
FAT Trace.
Linux C Events Path.
Aber den Befehl dazu weiß ich nicht.
Auf ein bestimmtes Verzeichnis eingrenzen.
Ich will das eigentlich nur für ein bestimmtes...
...Specific Device vielleicht?
Ach hier, Current Mount, was?
Ah! Das heißt, ich gehe jetzt da hin und sage...
CD, MNT?
Ne, äh, CD
Schuckt
Okay
Was macht Minus C?
ja gut aktuell ist denn beides alles wenn ich da rein ist wird nicht unbedingt wird
das denn bei beendet wird ja leute mal gespannt ob die jetzt liebt oder nicht
ich hätte mir aufschreiben sollen war nicht ins lieb gemacht habe
Tja
Jetzt können wir eigentlich nichts machen
Außer dumm warten
Chat, irgendwelche spannenden Themen
Für die letzten 10 Minuten
Wir hatten doch im letzten Stream was
Da habe ich gesagt, ich beantworte das
Im nächsten Stream
Und derjenige, der es wissen wollte
Soll sich doch nochmal melden, falls er da ist
Ist er denn da?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war
Ich glaube, ich habe mir das aber sogar aufgeschrieben
irgendwo, wenn ich es jetzt noch finden würde.
Habe ich vielleicht hier
irgendwie einen Text-File gemacht oder so?
Questions,
guck mal.
Hey Max, habe letztens meinen Master
gemacht, möchte mir mehr
DevOps-Zeug aneignen.
Habe schon vieles mit Docker gemacht.
Das höchste zu sagen, es sind so die Essentials.
Ist denn derjenige, der das gefragt hat,
überhaupt da? Ansonsten
macht es ja irgendwie keinen Sinn.
Welche ZFS-Version nutzt du?
Die, die aktuell in Proxmox Stable drin ist
Wo sieht man das?
Äh, Moment, Moment, ich hab grad was
Das hat sich grad so angehört, als hätte sich die Festplatte bewegt
Aber war nicht so
2.4 hat einen Sleep-Bug
Ach ja
Kann ich Z-Pool-Status machen, ohne dass die Festplatte aufwecke?
Anscheinend schon.
Wo sieht man denn die Version?
Oder muss ich ZFS-Get-Version oder irgendwie sowas machen?
Ja, ich hab die rausgezogen eben.
Einfach so?
Ne.
Der Chat lügt.
ZFS get
Version
Schuckt
Version 5
Hä?
Oder meinst du die
ZFS Version, die man hier irgendwie von dem Package
sieht?
Also 2.4
2.4
2-4 hat einen Sleep-Bug
Ja, 2-4
Wurde mal bei euch auf der Arbeit dummes Zeug gemacht
Also sowohl auf der alten als auch auf der neuen Arbeit
Wird selbstverständlich ab und zu dummes Zeug gemacht
Gegenwohl Dankeschön Für. Den Zap sorry Für. Die Perle ein bisschen nicht so zu rechnungsfähig für
Subscriptions sich Vielleicht üBersehen habe ich freue mich trotzdem dass ihr alle am start seid und besonders wenn Ihr subscribt
aber ganz ehrlich
Ich bin schön dass immer so viele da sind in Letzter zeit freut mich
Exzellent
Jetzt sage ich mal her
CX Timestamp DB Sync if idle causes unnecessary disk access.
Prevent spin down.
Oh.
Aber bis jetzt ist der spin down, ist es noch nicht wieder abgegangen anscheinend.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt hat die Platte gerade einen Sound gemacht
Ha, guck mal, der ist auf, ich habe nichts gemacht, der ist von alleine aufgemacht
Es gab keine Events da drauf
Dann ist das dieser Spin-Down-Bug, den ich hier auch habe anscheinend
Und was macht man gegen den Spin-Down-Bug?
Option
SPA Flush TX Time
Okay, was genau
hat das für Auswirkungen? Ist das wirklich
ein sinnvoller Fix?
Ich frage mal
Was macht das?
Schauen wir mal Google
Okay, was bewirkt der Welt konkret?
der parameter erhöht das zeitintervall für das erzwingen dieser schreibvorgänge
wenn das system ansonsten und das geht es absolut nicht sagen wieder stellt
Ja, Speedfighter
Das ist der Chat, der weiß einfach Bescheid
Ja, Baldi, es ist auch schön, dass du am Start bist
Also, was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Wir müssen hier zum Testen
Echo bla bla bla dahin
Okay
Das machen wir jetzt einfach mal
Jetzt sagen wir
HD Palm, wieder Standby
Jetzt watchen wir das Ding
Das scheint ein Bug zu sein, doch?
Gucken wir mal, ob der jetzt im Standby bleibt
Der wacht so alle
Ich würde sagen so 10 Minuten oder so.
Oder? Wann wacht der auf?
Hier, 10 Minutes.
Every 10 Minutes.
Okay, wir haben jetzt...
Moment.
Ja, wir haben es jetzt schon eine halbe Minute laufen,
aber sollte so, sollte passen.
Also gucken wir mal.
19.40 Uhr.
Wenn er 19.40 Uhr, 41 nicht abspinnt,
ab spinnt dann scheint funktioniert zu haben
preisgaben schön für den zap ich war bisher noch gar nicht fertig gelesen
wurde bei euch auf der arbeit auf das zeug gemacht in dem sinne dass feier
war es abgeschafft werden waren doch die haus zarteil für das blocken von dns
verwendet werden gerade auf der alten arbeit nur so viel schwachsinn gemacht
wenn ich da jetzt eine weile darüber nachdenke würden wir sicherlich auch
Sachen in dieser Richtung einfallen.
Aber viele der schwachsinnigen
Sachen habe ich ja in Videos teilweise schon erzählt,
beziehungsweise auch hier im Stream erzählt.
So ein
Riesending fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein, aber
gab's genug.
Gab's genug. Also eines
der lustigsten Sachen, wobei das jetzt nicht direkt
dummes
Zeug in Form von Firewall abschalten
war, ist, wo man
einen Servicetechniker, seinen USB-Stick
hat
in die Öffnung zwischen
Fahrstuhl
und Stockwerk fallen lassen.
Da, wo die Fahrstuhltür aufgeht.
Unter der Fahrstuhltür ist ja so ein kleiner
Spalt, ne?
Und da hat ein Servicetechniker beim Aussteigen
sein USB-Stick fallen lassen.
Und er ist genau in den Spalt
vom Fahrstuhl gefallen, runter
in den Keller und dort in eine Ölpfanne.
Das war dann RIP.
Und es war noch ein Wochenende. Es war noch nicht mal
einer da. Nur ich und ein Kollege
war da und es hat ewig gedauert.
Dann mussten die sich irgendwie per VPN
zu den Entwicklern nach Israel
tunneln, um sich dort eine neue
Firmware für das, äh, für das, für das, ähm,
für das Storage
schicken zu lassen. Das war ganz,
ganz abgedreht, äh.
dann da auch was von mk in etwa was ist was im kredit er das nur wenn ich
persistent machen will jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich ja nur zur runtime wenn
ich diese wenn ich will dass beim neustart dieser wert auch automatisch
gesetzt wird da muss ich in die module hier module config eintragen und dann
muss ich nicht das machen sondern das was man unter debian so macht update init ram fs oder
so glaube ich ist es unter debian ja so dinge haben wir alle schon mal hingekriegt
Ich bin da mittlerweile in der Tat relativ schmerzfrei, was, sagen wir mal in Anführungsstrichen, blöde Entscheidungen angeht.
Du musst gucken, also so wie es hier im Prinzip auch der Kalisterkoppel schreibt,
guck einfach, dass du das irgendwo schriftlich hast, wenn einer so dummes Zeug haben will.
Am besten noch, dass du mal darauf hingewiesen hast, dass es keine gute Idee ist.
Und wenn die dann sagen, doch, doch, mach, ey, ich bin nicht da, um euch hier zu retten.
Wenn ihr Blödsinn machen wollt, macht Blödsinn.
Ich sag's euch, dass es Blödsinn ist, wenn ihr es trotzdem machen wollt, dann meinetwegen auf eure Verantwortung.
Mehr als sagen kann ich es nicht.
Es gibt aber auch ein paar Sachen, die würde ich nicht machen.
Also wenn zu mir beispielsweise einer sagt, ich soll jetzt irgendwie für eine produktive Umgebung,
bei dir die Firewall ausschalten.
Dann ist mir egal, ob der Typ erstmal zuständig
ist für den Service oder nicht. Dann würde ich sagen,
wenn du es wirklich willst, gehst du zu unserer
Security-Abteilung, lässt dir das unterschreiben.
Dann mache ich das. Vorher nicht.
Kann mir einer erklären, was genau Schucken ist?
Mit Schucken ist gemeint
von einer externen
Festplatte. Also hier, ich habe hier so eine...
Ich habe leider die Kamera schon aus.
weil wir haben die festplatte schon laufen ich habe mir so ein ding hier gekauft so eine externe festplatte
und
schuppen heißt quasi auf deutsch so was wie entkernen man baut die interne platte aus der externen platte aus also die platte die die externe platte
verwendet baut man aus damit man sie als interne platte bei sich zum beispiel im nass verwenden kann das haben wir heute gemacht
Wenn du sehen willst kannst du einfach das wort angucken und irgendwie eine halbe stunde zurückgehen da siehst du schon
dass da eben geschockt wurde das war in der tat relativ easy muss man sagen
das war also es ging deutlich einfacher als gedacht war die günstig viel günstiger 499
euro was ist 750 euro für 26 t normale platte aber und das ist halt die frage ob es sich
wirklich lohnt du hast keine garantie mehr beinahe wendet jenis sie geld ein
wolf kaufst die kostet zwar 200 bis 300 euro mehr hat aber fünf jahre garantie
und wenn wir drei platten kaufst und nur eine geht davon kaputt in fünf jahren
hat sich schon nicht mehr gelohnt warum günstiger na ja weil die hersteller
ihre externen Discs irgendwie an den Mann
und die Frau bringen wollen.
An Festplatten Nutzende,
wie man das heute korrekt sagen müsste, oder?
Klingt nach einem 300 IQ Move.
Wie gesagt, es ist nur ein 300 IQ Move,
wenn deine Festplatten nicht kaputt gehen.
Wenn du Pech hast und die Festplatten gehen kaputt,
hast du keine Garantie drauf.
Also wenn du dir 5 Magen nimmst, du kaufst dir 5 Stück.
Ja, wenn du 5 Platten kaufst,
für fünf Jahre. Ich habe jetzt keinen Rechner
dafür, ja, aber ich sage mal, die Chance,
dass bei fünf Platten eine kaputt geht
in fünf Jahren, wird jetzt,
ich rate jetzt
einfach mal, keine Ahnung,
bei 10, 15 Prozent oder so sein.
Ich weiß es nicht. Einfach Bauchgefühl,
ja. Und dann ist halt die Frage,
hat sich das dann gelohnt?
Vielleicht lohnt sich es dann auch gar nicht mehr.
Das ist halt das Ding, ja.
Wieder einbauen,
so wie ich das auseinander genommen
habe, kriege ich das nicht, also ich kriege
das schon wieder zusammen, aber nicht, dass es so aussieht,
wie als wäre ich nie dran gewesen.
Ähm,
nein, es war nicht Dell EMC,
es war, ähm,
von IBM und Storage, was IBM zugekauft hatte.
XIV hieß das. Gibt's das noch?
XIV Storage.
IBM XIV Storage.
Discontinue 2018. Nice, GG.
Und da kamen die Firmenwerke, oder generell, glaube ich,
die ursprüngliche Firma, die die Dinger gebaut hat,
die kam, glaube ich, aus Israel.
ja hier
developed in 2002
bei an Israeli Startup Company
und IBM hat es
2007 gekauft
deswegen war aber die Firmwareentwicklung und sowas noch in Israel
und die mussten dann
irgendeinen VPN nach Israel bauen
dass die Entwickler dort
an einem Wochenende
über einen VPN
die Firmware die der Typ halt auf dem USB Stick
verloren hat
ihn wieder aufs Laptop schieben konnten
ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Hey Leute, das mit dem Idle Standby
scheint zu funktionieren, hm?
Ah nein, nee, gut. Wir haben noch,
wir haben noch. Ich hab nix gesagt, wir haben noch
zwei Minuten. Einfach Chat.
Dann muss ich aber auch off.
Spät, Boomer müde, schlafen.
Na, jetzt noch nicht ganz.
Schon spät.
Ja, ist übertreibtsweilig.
So müd bin ich auch noch nicht.
Aber wir haben noch zwei Minuten.
Ich sag trotzdem schon mal, Chat,
schön, dass so viele von euch wieder mit dabei waren.
Ich hoffe, euch hat der Stream gefallen.
Auch wenn es so kurz und knackiger Stream war.
Das Schucken ging schneller und einfacher als gedacht.
warum ausgerechnet jetzt ich hab die letzten die letzten 16 jahre nichts
weiß wie viel warum denn ausgerechnet jetzt
besser jetzt als früher weil es interessiert sich keine saube dafür
schwarz 33
Danke schön für den Sub.
Oh, Leute.
Ach, Mann.
Erkältung schnellst sackt.
Okay, du schon.
Sagen wir mal, es interessiert sich kaum noch einer für.
Ja, Leute, guck mal.
Es ist 19.40 Uhr.
Die Platte hat noch nicht geklackt und ist noch nicht aufgewacht.
Ich würde mal sagen,
das funktioniert.
Ja, ich muss gleich unbedingt noch was trinken.
Ich habe schon eine Tasse Tee, einen halben Liter Tee,
oder eher einen dreiviertel Liter Tee gesoffen,
während dem Stream, aber es hat trotzdem nicht gereicht.
Chat, das hat funktioniert?
Ihr seid high IQ.
Wer hat das geschrieben im Chat eben?
Mit dem, das ZFS, ein...
ZFS?
Sleep Bug?
Mayonnaise hat das geschrieben.
Okay.
Das ist echt
MVP Hinweis gewesen.
Moment.
Mayonnaise, bist du noch am Start?
Okay.
erstmal Besos ein bisschen Geld überweisen.
MVP-Hinweis.
Weil, ganz ehrlich, da hätte ich
bestimmt Stunden
gesucht, bis ich
das gefunden hätte.
Ah, jetzt hast du einen Sub.
Kannst ein bisschen Emote spammen.
Auch wenn ich noch 21 offene Emote-Slots hab.
MonkaS.
Ja, viel Spaß mit deinem Sub.
Leute, das ist Funst.
Wir haben geschuckt.
Die Festplatte bleibt im Standby.
Wir können das Ding power-offen.
Und jetzt muss ich unbedingt off.
Und noch was erledigen.
Power-off, power-off.
Moin, B-Side-Central.
Ich muss jetzt leider weg.
Wir sind schon fertig.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, Leute. Schön, dass ihr da wart. Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.